Yes,
Hollywood is a crazy world.
Even crazier history.
It's conniving,
competitive and above all risky.
I think to analyze movies,
it's important to understand the context
surrounding the production of the movie
that's mentioned.
It's also extremely interesting,
separate Hollywood's life into five
distinct areas and see the thievery,
desperation and failure in the industry.
Starting with
the first movies actually began far away
from Hollywood,
California.
All movies before 1911,
like the great train robbery in the
first Frankenstein movies were filmed
entirely on the east coast.
In fact,
the all too familiar term cliffhanger,
most likely,
originates from a series called the
peril of poly in 1914,
which was filmed in the former motion
picture capital of the country,
Fort Lee,
New Jersey.
The move to Hollywood happened for
several reasons.
It was cheaper.
There was nice weather year round in
California,
provided a lot of distinct film
locations.
Nothing illustrates this better than
paramount's description of the region.
One reason hardly talked about,
however,
is the fact that these million dollar
motion picture industries were fleeing
to California so they could more easily
break the law in 1891.
Thomas Edison patented the kinetic
breath that technology used to film
movies with his patent.
He had a legal monopoly on the entire
industry,
even at control over movie projectors
and film distributors.
Edison aggressively sued many people
using his adventure,
going so far as to hiring thugs to smash
cameras and rate independent studios.
Filmmakers like Fox and paramount had to
flee to the west coast so they could
make their movies outside of Edison's
influenced.
So technically any movie made before
1917,
not from Thomas Edison's production
company was completely illegal.
In 1917,
in the United States,
supreme court ruled his monopoly
unlawful and against public interest.
It's interesting how an industry founded
on breaking the rules is now
aggressively taking video essays down on
Youtube despite their obvious fair use.
But I digress.
Shall we try it right?
In the late 19 tents,
America cinema transitioned into what
we're familiar with,
the booming Hollywood industry.
The industry skyrocketed.
A key innovation was the addition of
dialogue in the late 19 twenties,
which kept the industry afloat popular
and innovative throughout the Great
Depression.
The era between 1917 in the late 19
forties is commonly referred to as
studio system Hollywood.
This is one production companies had
decade long contracts with actors,
directors,
and writers.
If you think the movie industry has
monopolized now,
know that five studios had control of
absolutely everything in the 19 forties.
Each major company had ownership of
actors,
directors,
distribution,
and even the movie theaters.
Creators could only make it an industry
if they stuck with one company for
almost their entire careers by signing
longterm and sometimes very unfair
contracts out of this era came.
Classics such as Gone With the wind,
Snow White and the seven dwarves and the
original Kong.
One interesting aspect of this time
period is that with so many movies being
made and so many people flocking to the
theater movie,
companies could afford producing movies
with medium sized budgets and scripts
that weren't necessarily blockbuster
material like citizen Kane and Casa
Blanca.
Nowadays,
big companies pull most of their time
and resources into several big budget
movies a year,
which is quite a shame.
The end of this era came from another
battle with the courts.
The Supreme Court ruled against
paramount pictures saying ownership of
the theaters and distribution of their
films was a restriction of fair trade.
This loss of control of distribution
protected independent filmmakers,
but meant to decline in the big
industry.
The next hit to movie popularity was
television.
Television hurt the industry.
Since many people could stay at home to
get their entertainment.
Movie viewership plummeted in the 30,
60 percent of people went to the movie
theaters at least once a week,
but since the 19 sixties,
the number has consistently stuck around
only 10 percent to combat TV.
Movies had to do what?
TV couldn't do,
big screens and big budgets.
The Hollywood epic came into fruition.
This is when movies got absolutely
insane.
Cinema scope lenses stretched the screen
to almost twice the size of conventional
film.
There were movies like Cleopatra in
1963,
which was the highest grossing film of
the year and still didn't make back its
budget.
One of its huge hundred foot set pieces
had to be built twice in two separate
countries because the lead Elizabeth
Taylor got sick
soon.
The new Hollywood era broke through.
Starting with Bonnie and Clyde,
film school trained directors gained
major influence in the industry as
opposed to the producers of old
Hollywood with low budget hits like jaws
by Steven Spielberg,
Star Wars by George Lucas and the
Godfather,
right?
Francis Coppola.
Producers gave more control to the
filmmakers who in turn produced more
provocative,
diverse,
and innovative movies.
Personally,
I find this atmosphere the most
conducive to amazing filmmaking,
but it came at a price with such
freedom.
Several films got way out of hand.
Many directors took their power too far
and movie budget skyrocketed out of
control.
Apocalypse now as an extreme example,
there's a documentary on the production
process of the movie called heart of
darkness that I absolutely recommend I
cannot come close to describing the
mayhem of making that movie in such a
short video.
Hurricanes heart attacks a coup in the
country they filmed.
It's crazy with apocalypse now in 1979
and the box office bombed heaven's gate
in 1980 bankrupting a huge production
company.
Producers tighten their grip on
filmmakers,
which makes absolute sense,
and what happened was in the seventies,
all those filmmakers that dig a final
cut,
the budgets grew and grew and each one,
one after the other had a financial
disaster that almost tore down the
studios.
If you treat the movie industry like an
actual business,
it's definitely one of the riskiest one
movie the public hates and it cripples
the company.
Millions are on the line and with
continuously decreasing ticket sales
companies had to adapt.
Now we're at the movie industry as we
know it today with home video in the
nineties and streaming services like
Netflix.
It's hardly worth it to drive all the
way to a movie theater anymore,
so companies make a handful of movies
and promote them.
Crazy superheros and fantasy movies
dominate box office sales because those
are the movies that are worth seeing on
the big screen.
Movies like pop star in the nice guys
bond this year because they're light
comedies and frankly I'm willing to wait
for them to come to Netflix and a couple
of months.
What's amazing about this era is that it
gets easier and easier to make feature
length movies.
I bought a used dslr camera tripod,
memory card case,
and editing software for less than $600.
You don't need a huge movie of
conglomerate to get your voice heard and
your art noticed.
Hollywood becomes more and more obsolete
every day.
So pick up your iphone,
hit record,
and say,
action.
Thanks for watching.
Just
need a ball bat.